la Sky Tower est une maison construite à
3 000 pieds au-dessus du sol, c'est
presque comme une station, c'est presque comme un
avant-poste militaire, c'est un quartier d'habitation,
mais c'est aussi un environnement de travail, c'est
une maison à trois niveaux qui se trouve évidemment sur ce tout
petit fuseau.  pas
quelque chose que vous pourriez construire mais j'avais l'impression
que nous pouvions nous rapprocher avant que le film ne
commence la photographie principale nous sommes allés à
Holly alcala un volcan à Maui nous avons installé
trois caméras qui ont capturé les nuages ​​du ciel le
lever du soleil les étoiles du coucher du soleil puis nous avons pris ces
images et nous avons projeté devant  sur un
écran massif qui entourait le décor,
cela donnait au film une sensation très épique si nous
devions faire cet écran bleu, tout ce
bleu que vous verriez à l'extérieur des fenêtres
se répandrait sur toutes ces surfaces et
tout ce verre et ce serait un
virtuel  cauchemar à peindre
et à gérer dans les effets visuels, donc la
possibilité d'obtenir ce truc à huis clos
qui est la caractéristique de conception essentielle dans
tout cet ensemble il n'y a pas d'écran bleu I
ce que vous voyez est le
produit final et nous sommes capables de changer le
temps au coucher du soleil et le lendemain il fait
jour et nous avons la nuit et tous les
nuages ​​​​se déplacent, c'est assez
incroyable ce que cela nous a permis de faire n'est
pas seulement  capturez-le à huis clos mais utilisez
la lumière réfléchie de cette séquence pour
éclairer réellement les décors et les acteurs
l'éclairage que vous êtes au-delà des
visages moyens est le même type de lumière
que pour obtenir un coucher de soleil car c'est
littéralement une séquence d'un coucher de soleil que vous finissez
avec un effet visuel de caméra tout compris et
une qualité visuelle, il ne peut tout simplement pas être truqué
et les acteurs apprécient vraiment aussi parce que
nous sommes en fait dans un endroit
entouré de nuages, cela aide en
tant qu'acteur n'agissant pas sur l'écran vert c'est
interactif donc vous n'avez pas à essayer d'
imaginer quelque chose que vous êtes là avec les
autres acteurs c'était très organique c'est
t2 c'est fantastique c'est une
œuvre d'art incroyable Je veux rester ici et
vivre ici Je veux emménager c'était  le
plus beau  l'ensemble sur lequel j'ai déjà tourné
leur permet même de
s'immerger plus profondément dans l'histoire parce
qu'ils en sont entourés,
donc c'est quelque chose que je suis vraiment
excité que nous ayons pu faire sur ce
film